hey
everyone my name is peter and i'm part
of the appsheep product team here at
google cloud
thanks for joining this session about
how to build ai powered
no code apps with appsheet i personally
work on
making appsheet as accessible as
possible for business users that don't
have coding experience to build apps
with appsheet
and i'm joined by my teammate tony who's
a senior engineer
focused on building ai into the platform
to make it easier to use
as well as into the end applications
that people can create to make those
apps
themselves really powerful thanks for
joining tony
hey peter thanks so today we're going to
walk through the basics of how to build
an application without writing code
in order to digitize a common business
process
after we do that we're going to look at
a few ways to make the app intelligent
and even more efficient by adding
machine learning to it great so for a
little background
a real serious challenge that many
businesses face is this growing demand
for improving their internal technology
but they frequently lack the skills and
resources to
update and build those solutions
internally
software that comes out of the box
rarely meets all the unique requirements
that a business has and so developing
custom solutions becomes necessary
real quickly but it's expensive it's
time consuming
and frequently just doesn't get done
there just aren't enough developers to
help tackle
all the opportunities for updating and
modernizing
process yeah and it's
uh it's even harder to use ai and
machine learning to make your
business workflows smarter the skill
sets for these are rare
it involves unique infrastructure for
building your applications
and configuring these things just takes
tons of time and so this is just
overhead that most organizations don't
have
so intelligent no code platforms
help solve this by enabling anyone to be
that app developer
ai expert no matter what their
background is
so machine learning uh baked into the no
code platform helps in three ways
first it makes app creation easier for
the user by guiding them along the
common pathways second it makes the apps
themselves more powerful and efficient
by say automatically doing data entry
for you
and third it makes governance even
easier and more reliable in the long
term
so no code apps can include all sorts of
powerful functionality
including collecting or managing data
more efficiently
automating business workflows and
sharing
insights with teammates taking advantage
of things like business intelligence
with dashboards
charts and reports yeah there's
there's opportunity for creating apps
that use features like those really all
throughout an organization
um it could be on the field with
customers it could be managing projects
it could be in you know like
manufacturing or distribution facilities
or in the office in a more corporate
setting but
some of the most valuable opportunities
are with desk-less workers
so these teammates don't necessarily sit
behind a computer during the day
and they're more likely to experience
friction trying to collaborate with
other teammates
or access important information just in
order to do their job effectively
so let's look at this example of how to
get started building a no code
application that helps a manufacturing
team
perform quality control inspections more
efficiently from their mobile devices
specifically let's digitize their
inspections taking it from a pen
and paper uh process to a mobile app
and then tony can help take that app and
make it even more efficient by
building a machine learning model into
it with uh with just a few steps
so how do you get started the to start
the process
you're connecting a data source to app
sheet to serve as the back
end of that application then we'll
define
an interface and behavior of that app in
app sheet before we share it with the
team
once it's in the hands of end users
those
updates that they're making in the
application gets synced right back to
that original data source
so let's open up app sheet and get
started building this particular app
in order to get this app started we want
to make sure that we have the data
source ready to go
in this case we're going to use a google
sheet here
and this google sheet has three tables
we have some recent inspection data
we have the parts that are being
inspected and we also have the employees
that are performing the inspections
so let's connect this to app sheet to
get this app started
we're going to connect to google
we're going to find this particular
google sheet
and app sheet's going to connect to that
initial inspections table then we'll
want to connect to the other two as well
while it's connecting to those tables
what's happening behind the scenes is
that it's
looking at the content of that data and
then building a relevant prototype
automatically based on what it can find
and so you can see we already have
a an application here that allows for
creating new inspections for viewing
those existing ones
and then also viewing the inspections on
a calendar
based on the dates in that data
let's connect the other two tables and
then let's customize this interface with
these three tables
connected now one thing that app sheet
was doing also behind the scenes was
intelligently
building relationships between the
tables based on what it could find based
on the fields that it's looking at
in these tables and so right because we
have a relationship
there are there are employees performing
the inspections and the inspections are
being performed on different parts
there's going to be relationships
between this data and that's already
represented in this
prototype of the application if we look
at one of these inspections
you can see that the part itself
has been connected and i can navigate to
the part details
when i'm looking at this part it has
related inspections that have been
performed on it i can also see the
employee who performed this particular
inspection i can go to that employee's
details
so with these relationships established
that just gives me a huge head start
on what type of functionality i can
expose in the application
and it makes uh it makes it a lot easier
than to now customize the app to be
exactly what i want for my ndap users
if i move into the ux section you can
see that there were a few different
views created but i want this
application to be fairly
i want this application to be fairly
straightforward and simple so i'm going
to go ahead and
remove a couple of these views and i'm
going to customize
the inspections view
and make sure that there is a dedicated
form view
to create new inspection entries
you can see throughout the editor
they're going to be suggestions for
what uh features and what elements might
be helpful
in your application
in this case what i'm looking at the
view types
i have an automatic view type that has
been selected i'd like to take advantage
of these
images that are being collected from
these inspection cards so i'm going to
use the card view
actually to better highlight those
images
what's advantageous about this card view
is that it provides a really easy way of
defining which fields get
exposed in the app interface
and so here i'm just going to go through
some of these different fields
maybe i want to show the employee and
the date of their inspection up top
and then the main image is already
selected and then i really want to
highlight whether or not
this inspection was accepted or rejected
and so i'll make that the primary header
and then i want to make sure that if it
is rejected that the
description of that inspection gets
highlighted
now i can i can include actions in this
view
to help navigate or initiate workflows
i'm going to remove those so it's nice
and clean so now i have a view here on
the right
showing those existing inspections that
have been
performed that i'm starting this
application with
last step here is because these are
inspection cards i'll put a relevant
view icon
of a card and i'd like alongside this
a quick way for my application users
to perform new inspections
when creating this view i'm going to
make sure that it is adding
new inspections to the inspections table
i'm going to make this
a form
and then i'll make this form icon
something relevant
like a magnifying glass and a plus sign
great so now this application consists
of two primary views
a way of adding new inspections and a
way of viewing existing
inspections let me go ahead and save
this app i want to make sure the app
logo is very relevant so my app users
recognize the application
and then because an important part of
this application is
really quickly identifying inspections
that have been rejected
i'm going to add a format rule that just
calls attention to rejected inspections
so in this case i'm going to say for
every inspection
where the condition equals rejected
i'm going to apply a format to that
particular condition field
and in this case i want a
let's see a little alert and i want the
text to be red
you can already see here on the right
that we're previewing that effect
so i'll go ahead and save this great
so now i'll open this application up and
preview it in tablet form and you can
get a better sense for
how those inspections that have been
logged by my employees
are visible and readily accessible and i
can also very quickly
get to the details of the different
employees and see inspections that are
that they have performed or for example
look at different parts that are being
manufactured and see related inspections
so one reason why this is valuable to
employees is that it's digitizing the
process and it's making this
information more reliably accessible
long term
another really important part of this
application is
getting the information in the into the
hands of the right people
more quickly than than it previously did
so one way that we can support that is
by building a workflow
in order to notify the right person or
the right team
as soon as an inspection has been logged
as rejected
so in this case let's build a workflow
that sends a notification email
to the right contact whenever a new
inspection has been logged that meets
this condition
in this case we're going to continue
looking at that inspections table
and we're going to say that every time a
new
row has been added
and the condition equals rejected
then we're going to send an email and
we'll send this
email to the operations team
and we'll want a relevant email subject
and then we can actually use a google
doc as the template
for this email so on the side here i've
created a google doc
that is just a simple layout that
includes some of the
fields from my app data i can use this
as a template for this particular email
and so if i include a link to that
template
every time this workflow will run it
will draw from that template and send an
email formatted
based on that google doc layout great
now let's test what happens when we add
a new
inspection to this application we can
use a photo of a recently inspected tag
that's come off one of the parts
this part has been marked as rejected
and i'll fill in some of the details
here
submitting a form in a nap sheet app
passes that data right through to the
connected data source so in this case
it's going to add a row
to the google sheet and that added row
triggers the workflow that will send the
email notification
to the team
so at this point the app is ready to
start being used and i can get it to the
team by sending individual email invites
i can
invite just a group from my organization
or i can make it accessible to the
entire domain and then i can share a
link that
is accessible by any user on their
mobile device or on their desktop okay
so we've got the foundation of this app
created and it's already ready
for the team to be using so they can
capture their inspections digitally
instead of just with pen and paper
so they're already using the app they're
already collecting these tickets in the
application
the real gains from this particular app
are going to come by
incorporating this ai model specifically
using some of that existing data
to build an ocr model so tony can you
walk us through
that stage right now
so peter just talked about how to build
this cool quality control
app that allows you to move from a
paper-based process to a digital process
where instead of employees filling out
paper forms
they're using this mobile app to take
pictures of these tickets and to
transcribe the information in them so
what i'm going to talk about next
is how to take advantage of the data
that is now being collected via this
mobile app
so you can think of every time your
employee uses this app
they take a photo of one of these
quality control tickets
and then enters in information so we're
building up a data set
now we can use ai and machine learning
to take advantage of the data that we've
collected
and further enrich the app by making it
more efficient and easier to use
so let me give you a quick tour of some
of the ai features
that are available in app sheet so i'm
going to navigate to the intelligence
tab in the app sheet editor
and the first feature i want to show you
is the smart assistant feature
so the smart assistant feature enables a
google assistant like experience
inside of your mobile app but customized
to your business domain
so once you flip this switch in the
editor you get your own
custom assistant that understands
natural language
let me give you a couple examples so to
access the assistant
i go to this view that's available in
the side menu of my app
called assistant and here i can do
things like this
can you show me the inspections from
last month
so the assistant takes my uh question
like this and understands it in terms of
the data and concepts that are in my app
can you show me just the rejected ones
so you can see that it understood what i
said and further filtered the data down
to just the rejected inspections
uh can you show me more information
about the rotary piston
so this is just a couple examples of the
types of interactions you can have with
the
smart assistant feature and app sheet
now i'd like to show you
app sheets ocr or optical character
recognition features
so let's go back to the inspection data
that we've been collecting
so you can see i've got a quality
control ticket image taken with a mobile
device
and then i've got the information that
we've transcribed down below
so in our current process the employee
needs to both take a photo
and then manually transcribe the
information from the ticket
i'm going to show you how you can use
ocr to automate this process
and go directly from a picture of one of
these tickets
and have a filled out form based on the
content from the image itself
so this ocr feature leverages google
cloud vision
api this means that
business users have access to the same
powerful machine learning algorithms
that were traditionally limited to
software engineers before
so let me walk you through the steps
that you need to take in order to
add this type of ocr capability to the
app sheet app
so the first thing i'm going to do is
create a new ocr model
so what an ocr model is is it's a way of
looking at the examples of the data that
we've already collected
and coming up with a machine learning
model that can then
extract from new images that haven't
been seen in the data set before
so the first thing i need to do is
choose my table in this case
i'm going to choose the inspections
table because that's the data that i
want to use this on to
go from the picture of an inspection
ticket to these extracted fields
next i need to specify the image column
in this case there's just a single
column in my data set called image
this is going to be the inputs of the
model then i choose the output
these are the columns in the data set
that i want to predict in this case it's
automatically selected
the other columns in the table like
condition part number
quantity and so on so this is the
how i specify the model and when i press
save what's going to happen
is actually it's going to look at the
data that's already in my table
these examples you see over here on the
right and it's going to use a machine
learning model
to figure out common patterns of where
these
values appear in the images so i'm going
to press save
cool now that the page has reloaded the
ocr model has been trained and we can
actually inspect it to see what it
learned from the data set
so i'm going to scroll down a little bit
and
you can see here below uh my model
i have the examples from my training set
if i click on them you can see that
it's found out where in the image the
columns
in my table are found so for example
this yellow piece right here at the
bottom
is identified as where the description
is located in the image
and it identified that the word rejected
up here corresponds to the condition
field in the
the same table so it's gone through
these ten or so examples that we've
already collected via
regular use of the app and figured out
how to generalize from it
and uh now we can use it to identify uh
where these fields are automatically in
new images so let me give you an example
of that
so i'm going to go back to the app here
and i'm going to click on the new
inspection
button at the bottom so you can see this
is the form that the app creators have
been using to fill out the app so far
so now i'm going to upload a new image
to the form
this is an image that wasn't already in
the table so the app hasn't seen this
before
so i've selected the image
and now you can see that it's
automatically filled out the rest of the
form with values from the image
so for example it got the date as july
26 2020
from the upper right hand corner of the
image
so you can see once you start using app
sheet to
digitize your paper-based processes you
start getting
compounding returns uh once you collect
a data set it becomes more valuable
because you can use ai and machine
learning algorithms on it
however you don't have to be an expert
to use them anymore we provide
no code interfaces to it that allow
business users
to create their custom machine learning
models for their particular business
domain
these algorithms are built on top of
google cloud ai features
so you get the same powerful machine
learning capabilities that were
traditionally only available to trained
software engineers
but now you can access them without
writing any code at all
great thanks tony so in 15 minutes
we've digitized this inspection process
with a custom app
that uses ml models built in you know
and built from existing business data
and what we've shown can really be built
by anyone on the team
who sees an opportunity to innovate and
who understands
you know how to improve this particular
process
so um tony i'd like to just expand on a
few topics that are related to what we
just
showed and the first is i'm curious you
know based on this application and
and where it is right now where do you
think would be some natural next steps
to take it to extend the functionality
for this particular scenario
yeah so one thing i didn't talk about my
demo was
app sheets predictive models so
predictive models allow you to
automatically categorize records based
on the data that you've collected so far
so for example in this inspection
ticketing
scenario what you could do is have
the platform automatically categorize
these tickets based on the words that
appear in the description
you could then use that categorization
to route failures or rejections to the
right team
so this is another way that you can use
cloud a high-powered machine learning
without having to be a programmer
great yeah so and the example that we
just showed and then and then also the
extension that you just described
um is there a particular example of a
customer that has built
a similar solution and you is using it
with their team that you can
describe a little bit yeah so as an
example we've got a customer from the
construction industry who's starting to
roll out an ocr powered app
and so what they have is an app sheet
powered
workflow already where they have truck
drivers uh driving
picking up goods and delivering them to
work sites
and every time they do this they have to
use their mobile phone to take a picture
of like a trucking ticket or a receipt
um they're already using an app sheet
app to do this and then a qa person
downstream uh goes through those images
that they
uh the truck drivers captured and
manually transcribes all the information
from them like the shipment weights and
the date and the time
um but because they already have this
workflow uh built on an app sheet app
they're able to just extend it further
uh using the the platform's ocr
capabilities so now the qa person
doesn't have to go through and
transcribe every ticket
which would take you know minutes for
every ticket and they have hundreds of
these tickets
uh now they can uh just actually have
the ocr system automatically fill out
the forms and then they can just verify
to make sure it's
correct so this just saves tons of time
for these qa people
yeah very cool thanks tony so finally um
can you just give us
a quick synopsis or description of what
is around the corner for ai
in the option platform yeah so there's a
couple things i can highlight
so one is the platform itself
is becoming more and more intelligent
giving
app creators suggestions as they build
their app
making it easier to go from an idea to a
fully functioning app
a second way that it's uh we're
improving things is
allowing you to build workflows based on
uh cloud ai
[Music]
technology so for example having a
workflow where you upload a document
it's automatically categorized routed to
the right person
um and classified further and the third
direction
is deeper integrations with google
cloud's machine learning offerings
to make it even easier for apps to
understand your unstructured data
that's great thanks for sharing tony
it's real exciting to see
sort of how the platform the apps
themselves are continuing to get
new ai features so just to recap what
tony's described
and and what we've shown here in in
these couple demos is having ai built
into the no code apps as well as into
the authoring environment
it really just boils down to apps being
easier to
to make and and being capable of really
powerful functionality
and really importantly all along the way
because
this is uh entirely in a no code
environment it's really easy to control
with
organizational level policies that are
real simple to set up
and they're easy to maintain long term
so with that thank you tony for your
work making this functionality available
and for helping demonstrate it today
and thank you everyone who has joined
the session
and are watching this video i know i
speak for the team when i say that we're
excited to have new users joining and
creating really interesting and powerful
solutions for their own teams there's a
real strong community of app creators
here
at app sheet and throughout google and
and honestly all over the world
that are ready to help share ideas and
help you get started
in the platform so if you'd like to
learn more and try it out
you can find app sheet in google cloud
or directly at appsheet.com
thanks